l'histoire ne sais pas mais je sais
c'est très marrant l'homme ce mammifère
si particulier a toujours été à vis de
progrès pour améliorer son existence il
s'était passé pour créer les inventions
qui ont changé le cours de sa propre
histoire telle que le train à vapeur le
téléphone ou les apéricubes mais comment
a donc eu lieu
l'invention de la télécommande c'est ce
que nous allons vous raconter dans cet
épisode de l'histoire racontée par des
chaussettes alors aux gènes
est-ce que vous avez avancé sur le truc
dont vous m'aviez parlé la dernière fois
oui un génial montrez moi ça je suis
impatient je vais le chercher deux ce
pas ok j'ai oublié ce que c'était le
truc parce que j'avais un oncle un truc
c'était les chaussures à hélices non les
voitures à lyss non le fromage à hélice
non ce n'était pas ça c'était votre
projet est top secret révolutionnaire
souvenez-vous au mais bien sûr vous êtes
prêt au plus près que ça ça me ferait de
la peine
eugène qu'est ce qui vous énerve le plus
quand vous regardez la télé ma femme
d'accord mais à part votre femme les
communistes et aussi de devoir bout de
devoir vous lever pour pour un pur pour
changer de chaîne
ouais non si je vous dis qu'il existe un
objet qui vous permettrait de changer
les chaînes de télé sans soulever je
vous dirais que c'est ma femme
d'accord mais au cours des années 50 un
mail à votre femme allait pas affamé pas
la mode femme est pas là et elle est pas
avec monsieur stevens en train de faire
des trucs bizarres
elle est pas avec monsieur steven
tentant de faire des trucs bizarres et
on n'est pas jeudi
j'ai pas golf et on n'est pas jeudi
faisait pas golfe nous écoute
si j'avais inventé cet objet qui change
de chine sans bouger de votre canapé
qu'est ce que vous me diriez je vous
dirais sorcellerie brûlures si vous
hésitez pas catholique extrémiste
vous irez formidable gn montrez moi ça
je frétille d'impatience bougeait pas
j'y retourne de ce pas c'était la
pareille à changer les chaînes
voilà c'est inventer
s'il n'existait pas il faudrait
l'inventer
tadao c'est donc ça oui exactement et
j'ai appelé ça égouttez le flash matic
mais est-ce que c'est pas un peu trop
rectangle dont le nom est pas bien la
fin on peut la changer
comment ça marche ah bah ça c'est simple
on appuie sur la chaîne de son choix et
ça change automatiquement
donc si je veux voir la quatrième chaîne
à bas facile et si je veux voir la 2 la
3 la saq black hat la deux la une
si j'ai envie de l'a6 et l'a31 l'a5 l'a4
l'a3 et l'a6 la deux la une
l'a3 l'a6 la deux la une l'a4 l'a6 est
la 2 la 3 la 4l l'atelier la saisine
l'a3 l'a12 l'a6 à une blague la une à la
une de la croix la galaxy 2 1 3 2 2 6 6
3 6 3 alors qu'est ce qu'on en dit
eugène au lundi qu'il faut que je vends
un casque et c'est ainsi qu'après
plusieurs réajustements eugene polley
inventa en 1955 la télécommande
la commotion cérébrale en tout cas
d'après des chaussettes mais dites-moi
eugène sue bidule ça marche avec des
ondes
oui est-ce que c'est pas un petit peu
dangereux non c'est très marrant